okay guys the finale is coming up the
final episodes are airing what can fans
expect that's what we want to know
what's the T it's just spill something
anything you expect it will be the
complete opposite yeah yeah yeah last
time I spoke to you though you did tell
me you weren't super thrilled about the
finale until it came into fruition when
you read it you weren't so super excited
about it but now you've changed your
mind no I think it's you know it's it's
this is a show that like asks a lot of
questions and and it puts you in a very
contemplative headspace even with all
the fart jokes and so I think that I was
processing it probably and now I'm now
that I've processed it I've come to a
place of Zen with it and so uh and so I
yeah I mean like I I do feel like where
we end is we're where we need to fare
not okay so you've experienced heaven
hell and earth do you have a favorite
I don't know I like I like I like earth
earth was great we're traveling around
in different countries doing all the
weird things crushing taxis with monster
cars yeah Liz yeah it's a good time yeah
I mean I actually really enjoyed the bad
place I think it's just so everything
everyone is so funny and it's just so
mean and juvenile and the best ways I
love it do you guys go on social media
at all and see what the fans are saying
about the show I think you can help but
you know receive the love and all you
know all the attention that comes from
the show you kind of have to put like a
guard up because if you take too much of
that can get a little overwhelming yeah
you can also get your feelings hurt
you know like come across a mean tweet
about yourself you dislike oh yeah
always the bad ones that stick yeah yeah
regardless of how much love we get it's
always the bad ones that like damn you
like that's what I get that's what I get
for you know but uh yeah I mean it's
like it but it is fun to watch people's
reactions and see what they're taking
away from it
what's the group chat like you all have
a group chat yeah we do a lot of memes a
lot of new pain oh yeah just a lot of
silliness going on yeah a lot of love -
a lot of heart emojis yeah yeah I know
that you are you gonna be at the Critics
Choice Awards tomorrow okay so I know
that you're nominated for a Critics
Choice Award do you have your speech
ready
no no nothing and no I thoroughly expect
to lose so I'm like you know I mean
seriously I do so like I have nothing
prepared but I'll you know I'll figure
something out tonight just in case on
the outside chance that I don't wind up
up there you know but um yeah I totally
was just like I was like oh that's
that's nice then I got nominated and I
left it there that's that's that's the
win for me I don't really need anything
else tomorrow and lastly what is that oh
yes and lastly what are you guys up to
now the good place it's coming to an end
I'm so sad I know something about the
Underground Railroad you guys tell me
what you're up to I we have top gun'
coming out in June of 2020 and then you
also have a show on Netflix called
brand-new cherry flavor a horror
thriller thing going on complete
opposite at the good place so we'll see
we'll see how it goes probably sometime
next year
yeah yeah we're wrapping a pretty quick
yeah that should be the group yeah and
then you lastly
Underground Railroad and I'll just see
what else I can get involved with you
know beyond that it's um that's got me
occupied right now and so you know once
we get past that I'll be looking further
down the road awesome thanks for your
time guys